the harlem cultural festival felt like
lightning in a bottle the harlem
cultural festival of 1969 welcome to the
holland culture festival nobody ever
heard of the harlem culture festival
nobody would believe that happened 50
000 beautiful people here in mountain
park my producers robert five joseph
patel and david dinnerstein they showed
me that footage
this was real
a day after the death of dr martin
luther king after the assassination of
martin luther king many in inner city
from detroit to philadelphia to atlanta
places were just erupting and anger
righteous anger people for that year had
been dealing with constant loss there's
so many people who need help the loss of
the kennedys the loss of malcolm x
martin luther king all the civil rights
leaders
not wanting to repeat what happened the
summer of 68 the city allowed for this
festival to happen we needed something
to really reach out and touch us we
needed that music
[Music]
growing up in a musical family my dad
would often play the apollo theater in
harlem during that period amir is
someone who knows a lot about music and
it's very authentic i'm the guy that
watches every music documentary and i'm
always like they got that wrong like
that's the wrong year he can go down a
really nerdy path right like this bass
player used to play with that guitarist
and they used to have a band before this
and they did this one song that was a
cover of another song even people with
the highest musical intelligence had no
idea that this took place like wait a
minute like stevie wonder and the
staples singers and sly on the family
stone that happened in 69 and no one
ever heard of this i was like okay well
i guess this is my destiny to
tell the story there were over 47 reels
of footage miraculously it sat in hal
tolson's basement for 50 years
we had to restore it so that took five
months alone for them to just go frame
by frame by frame dusting it making sure
that it didn't snap or anything we got
that footage
it was damn near perfect
the great irony of this is that because
no one
wanted to do anything with this footage
at the time and through the years
the footage was actually in remarkably
good shape
for four to five months i lived with the
footage inside my household i constantly
kept that concert on a loop and if
something intrigued me i would take
notes during those five months i would
come across some mind-blowing footage my
jaw would drop
while there were five camera angles at
the event itself they had done their own
live
camera mix
it did not have the isolated camera
footage
i knew that we should actually approach
the editing like you do your dj gigs we
should be
just as rhythmic this film is his dj set
one of many things that amir brings to
the project as a director as a
storyteller is his perspective as a
musician often times when i curate
things there's kind of a
rhythmic feng shui thing that i
i don't know how to describe yet my job
was to basically be the turntables you
find ways to blend songs into each other
i think he understands pacing incredibly
well he was ready to be a director and
ready to tell this story in particular
he really had strong ideas about certain
tracks he wanted to start with the
stevie wonder drum solo
[Music]
i knew that i wanted the first five
minutes of the film to just gob smack
the person watching and when i saw
stevie wonder take a drum solo i was
like yo this is something that even
stevie wonder experts really haven't
seen before i just knew like
that was my first scene understanding
that that was going to be showing
audiences something that they had never
seen before i just realized the genius
of it it's just the perfect thumb print
for a mirror on this film not only was
the source material phenomenal to start
with but the sound quality of the source
material was phenomenal
[Music]
because it was a primarily black
festival for a primarily black audience
in the black epicenter of the country
there wasn't a lot of newspaper
clippings or anything else that we found
announcing the festival i think the
obvious answer is racism right like i
think let's not beat around the bush up
to that point black identity was in
question everyone dressed the same they
wore tuxedos they did uh choreograph
moves
you had to filter and make yourself
palatable so that you wouldn't scare
white people people watching in texas
people watching it in ohio and that's
where we were as a culture and it
reflected in the music and it reflected
in the message as well
so many luminaries came together from bb
king gladys knight the pips that is
[Applause]
now when i stepped on stage i was
totally taken aback because i didn't
expect a crowd like that
ladies and gentlemen
the tamers brothers
there was max roach and abby lincoln
slat music african music
sliding the family stone hugh masakayla
fifth dimension their set is incredible
it's just so catchy and colorful so many
just amazing performers
you know occasionally my jaw would drop
especially in watching that mahalia
mavis movement
[Music]
i just stood in front of my television
i'm like yo that's crazy
ladies and gentlemen
nina simone
[Music]
for her there was a burning desire to
stand up for black people and really
give a message on why they are important
why they are beautiful
[Music]
you could feel the artists drawing
energy from the audience you know i
think it was clear that the artist knew
that something magical was happening
it's just something to see
black america has lost faith in this
country 1969 was such a transformative
period somebody better wake up
day by day month by month we started
noticing the parallels of 1969 and 50
years later the same things that they
were talking about back then were
happening to us right now we want a new
life a black consciousness revolution
it reflects and brings to the forefront
a moment in time that might give us some
insight into where we are today
culturally the one takeaway that i hear
from people who had the opportunity to
see the film at a festival prior to its
opening is about how topical the film
actually is there's an easy takeaway to
see all of the parallels
about
social injustice about you know love of
community unfortunately how things
really have not evolved much in over 50
years
we need it now there are important
themes to this movie and important
things that it says about where we are
as a society we have a responsibility to
show the people the social and political
circumstances with poverty how the
government treats its citizens how the
police treated citizens the idea of
protesting and letting your voice be
heard the revolution is not going to
stop
everybody
i don't want people to get the feeling
that this is a history lesson in any way
we all put a lot of work and energy into
making sure that this is a joyful film
the the music in the film and the
performances are so exuberant it makes
you proud to be part of a world where
this could happen we'd be remiss if we
didn't
acknowledge people that attended the
festival because of the historical way
that community has been treated you
can't just get to people through social
media you have to meet them on the
ground that was really difficult it's
not as easy as it seems because 50 years
ago is a very long time in the case of
moussa jackson he told us that this was
his very first memory the things that he
described in detail were sort of like
okay he really remembers this their
outfits were orange but it was orange
like you know remember the creamsicles
like at the very end then we showed him
the footage
[Music]
he wasn't expecting that and then that's
when the tears just came rolling
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's when i realized like
oh this this is that type of film like
this isn't just
a cool concert like you are
you're giving people back their memories
i'm not crazy
thank you
this incredible thing did happen and
it's really important to to preserve
that memory not only for the people who
went but also for the rest of culture
at the end of the day i think a lot of
the news just came to be because us
discovering you know black is beautiful
instead of always trying to pander and
please and readjust our lives to make
certain people feel safe
let's please ourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
take the first